hi I'm Joan gasps Claire thank you for
coming and speaking of that pleasure and
throughout our time together you've
talked about different aspects of your
leadership both empowering other people
building coalitions and supporting an
emerging youth population and I was
wondering if you could share with us one
or two decisive moments in leadership
and that you face and what leadership
characteristics you think are most
important from those moments this is a
tough question some years ago when i was
young i was elected to the Georgia
Legislature and just prior to my being
sworn in I endorsed a statement issued
by the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
that was critical in the Vietnam War and
if i told you that statement today you'd
say well that's nothing that's what
people say about the war in iraq or the
war in afghanistan it's not in temperate
it's okay but then it appeared to be
radical and many people were upset by it
and my colleagues to be in the
legislature put threatened to put me out
if I didn't apologize or take this the
statement back well I couldn't apologize
i believe to the saving I couldn't take
it back I thought it was right and
correct so I didn't know what to do and
I you know I worked hard to get elected
I'd kiss babies had shaken hands I'd
done all those things and I wanted to
have this seat I'd one and I was exiting
a restaurant in Atlanta and I ran into
the Reverend having at Ralph Abernathy
was dr. King's closest associate and I
said dr. Abbott I know what I wish can
do he want me to apologize I don't think
I should apologize they want me to take
it back i'm not going to take it back
what can I do he said just do something
you can live with and I thought well
I'll do that and I did somebody live
with I didn't take it back I didn't
apologize I stood up for it and while it
didn't happen right away eventually i
won my seat back in the legislature I
went to the Supreme Court and they ruled
in my favor and ordered the legislature
to put me back in so that's always been
kind of a lifeline to me do something
you can live with I never won't do
something i would be embarrassed by
something that i'd be ashamed of later
although i'm sure i've done some things
I shouldn't have done but I I've just
have like that statement do something
you can live with and you know
I've tried to always do something I can
live with and so far I've been able to
do so